did you see miley cyrus drop herself in
it with her preference remarks showing
underlying transphobia
i didn't why don't you fill me in on
that one i'm not up on my miley cyrus
well
let me tell you this is in out.com by
may
rude not sure if that's a real name so
this is this is the gay press
is out.com it will well it sounds a bit
gay
that's only you can say that miley cyrus
is making waves with new comments about
her sexuality
in a new interview she not only says
that she prefers women to men but also
attempts to explain why
girls are way hotter we know this the 28
year old bisexual said in an interview
with siriusxm's bar stool radio
everyone i think can agree that from
ancient times dicks make wonderful
sculptures
other than that i'm not as interested i
like dicks as p art pieces
and sculptural i love the shape i think
it looks really good on a table
the singer continued it's good if i can
just get it in and go away
because i don't want to eyeing me up
that's how i truly feel
i really feel good about saying that she
dug it even deeper
adding everyone knows that tits are
prettier than balls
that's what ended up making female
relationships make more sense to me and
then this
cuts back to may roode i wish that i
could say this news makes me excited and
proud to be a woman and a lesbian but
cyrus's quote is littered with
transphobia
this kind of gender essentialism was
left behind by most of the queer
community years ago genitals do not
equal gender
and miley should know this and then it
just keeps on going in an age where
turks are more vocal than ever
people like miley believe that genitals
determine gender trans women and girls
are often considered to be in public
spaces trans women should be kicked blah
blah blah this isn't the first time
she's gotten in hot water
she seemed to imply that being gay is a
choice i don't think that miley meant
to traffic in turf talking points but
the fact is she did
and should know better the stakes are
too high for someone with as big of a
spotlight on her is accidentally
spreading this sort of
rhetoric miley i love you but i'm going
to need you to make this right and i'm
sure that miley cyrus
really took that to heart i'm sure
the incredible entitlement of that kind
of article is is insufferable isn't it
and it's um uh not only actually did i
read that i
i tweeted about it so when i said i
hadn't heard of it it's because i it's
because i read this stuff every day
that it could have been anyone talking
about anything
i mean the idea that if you find breasts
more attractive than
a scrotum uh that is a turf
viewpoint you know that phrase is just
ludicrous anyway turf
um that it is in some way transphobic
uh you see this all the time generally
genital preferences are are transphobic
no they're not
they're obviously not but i shouldn't
have to say it's obviously not the case
uh that is true i mean and also the idea
listen to what she said in the article
the queer community left this behind
years ago
most gay people have genital preferences
sorry to break this to you
the vast major you've clearly never been
on a cruising ground i tell you what
because it's it is very very much about
the genitals and don't you tell me
that suddenly people are blind they're
blind to what what is in the
what is in the underwear department they
don't care are you kidding go on grindr
that's all
that's all they care about pretty much
yeah i mean
the um the funny the funny thing
that i saw there was it was like we
talked about grievance hierarchies right
it was like the hierarchy
of different things that she'd done so i
kind of had it in my head i could
imagine this kind of like quite
haughty um foreman working
like looking over a building site and
he's like looking he goes that
feminism women yeah check lesbian yep
women
check oh we're looking good here oh oh
you haven't you haven't quite got it
right you didn't quite get it right on
the transphobia did you i'm gonna have
to
i'll give you i'll give you a b minus
and uh you can hand this in at reception
and we'll see if we can get you back
next week
you know what i mean like is it some
sort of calling card
i mean for one thing like it's such a
shame we even have to discuss like the
article sounds
banal doesn't it it sounds why do i care
what
what miley cyrus thinks about tits i
don't care about that it's so
it's really not interesting i've i've i
can pretty much guarantee i've got no
interest in anything she's got to say
but that is
that really uh that really takes a bit
so why am i even having to talk about
this well it's because
journalists uh are picking through
sifting through
everything that people say and trying to
find some way to turn it into an
offensive comment how boring what a
boring
existence this person must have and